Let's see if we can
write 0.36 as a fraction.
There are several
ways of doing it.
The way I like to do it
is to say, well, 0.36,
this is the same thing
as 36 hundredths.
Or one way to think
about it is this
is in the hundredths place.
This is in the
tens place, or you
could view this
as 30 hundredths.
You could view this as 3
tens, or 30 hundredths.
So we could say that this is
the same thing as 36 hundredths,
or this is equal to 36/100.
And we've already
expressed it as a fraction,
but now we could
actually simplify it
because both 36 and 100
have some common factors.
They're both divisible
by, well, looks
like they're both
divisible by 4.
So if we could
divide the numerator
by 4 and the
denominator by 4, we're
doing the same thing to both.
So we're not changing the
value of the fraction.
36 divided by 4 is 9, and
then 100 divided by 4 is 25.
And now these two
characters don't
seem to share any
other common factors.
And so we've written
it in simplified form,
and we're done.